wait is it true speaking of kids when
you were a kid the person who helped you
find an agent discovered you eating
pizza somewhere yes what did the person
say to you in the pizza place and were
you eating a pizza I was eating a pizza
it was after dance class one day and
then I think we have pizza here I like
thank you John thank you so much okay so
you're in a pizza place this is great
and someone comes up to you what do they
say um um he said uh I'm I'm I work at
Revlon and I like he talked to my mom
and he was like I you know would she be
interested in like child modeling or
whatever and it was obviously a little
like is this a real person or a creepy
person but he was actually very nice and
like and I was um not really interested
in like modeling but I really like
performing so I was like do you know any
acting agents and he introduced me to
acting agents and that's how it all
happened
yes you guys may December this film is
one of the greats when you're watching
it you're like this is what great film
making is this is phenomenal I'm so
grateful that you put and you produced
this thank you yes again what can't
Natalie Portman do look at what
you three thank you okay everybody made
December streaming on Netflix now and we
make this show for you and when it
includes Natalie Portman I feel lucky to
be a part of it so take it with
[Applause]
[Music]
you